now I think the function they give you
is is it 5x minus 1 family 12 plus 1
thank you so let's just start out by
writing this let's define a new function
f of X and it's 5x plus 1 so what we're
going to do to this thing is making a
difference yet and we're going to do it
during using the process that we did
before okay so here's what I'm going to
write instead of saying derivative or
grade in the tangent I'm just gonna say
f dash X okay and then we will say
what's it going to be equal to well do
you remember I have to start off by
writing this limit thing right I'm
figuring out the great need of a tangent
not a secant so I always begin by
writing this and hopefully just like a
page earlier in your book you've got the
difference question right what is it's a
it's a question right what is the
difference question it's f of X plus h
minus f of X all divided by H yeah Joey
to pause on a thing or explain something
for you okay
fantastic so this is the general
definition this is what the the
derivative is for any function but I've
got a specific function 5x plus 1 okay
so let's have a go at replacing
everything for this which is general
which which with this which is specific
okay so if this is my function 5x plus 1
what's f of X plus h what would I write
5 lots of S Plus H thank you very much
Selena there we go and then I'm gonna
add one I'm just gonna pause right there
okay so this thing here is f of X plus h
just gonna highlight it for you that's
the first thing I'm looking at there it
is right there I've just changed every X
and replaced it with an X plus h okay so
that's good takeaway what's my f of X
have a look just by definition it's that
guy right now just be careful because
I'm subtracting a whole function I'm
gonna Chuck some brackets in here
because there's going to be a minus sign
that sort of distributes to everything
in here is that alright so
there there is my f of X and I've just
done a straight swap
how are you so far so far so good okay
that's the numerator what's left in my
difference question the denominator
which is over H very good now at this
point last time actually we had
something I threw you guys right in the
deep end I had something much more
complicated there was squares and all
that this is easy to deal with right
first thing to write down is ah first
things I write down is the limit why am
i dealing with the limit why do I keep
writing that down look at these two
lines if I don't write the limit what am
i working on I'm working out the
difference quotient which is a secant
right but I don't want to secret that's
just an approximation just like us
measuring with our triangles I want
something precise the tangent okay so I
have to write yeah yeah great question
read the question so I'm pretty sure if
says it'll tell you I'll tell you once
though I will point out the only reason
we really we're talking about sequence
this morning is because they are the way
to get to tangents okay
so right right exactly okay all right
can you help me out can we do a bit of
expansion and collecting my terms
yep very good 5 X plus 5 h plus 1 done
with that help me out with the second
one resident fantastic now if we did
this right should do the whole fraction
first if we did this right some stuff
should cancel right what can you say
these guys by the way is it obvious
enough that I'm trying to help you see
this with colors right there's lots of
stuff that will be more obvious see if
you can just highlight it in this way
good fantastic
so if you did it right lots of stuff
should cancel and we get left with what
just the 5 H 5 H over H so you're like
oh cool this is the thing I saw before
right I can get rid of the H's so I say
this now at this point you're like oh
what happens when H gets closer and
closer to 0 what happened
two-five as H gets small as well and the
answer is nothing happens to fire five
just stays five okay now let's just
pause now that we've got an answer and
think about what this means what is it
that we set out to try and calculate
you're differentiating words that tell
us what is this thing
it's the now it's to do with the tangent
what does it tell us about the tangent
the gradient of the tangent now what
this is saying is you notice there's no
X there it's no X so in other words
whatever value of x I try out the
grainier the tangent apparently is
always five why is that what is this
object that we're dealing with this
object is a linear graph is a straight
line right so you're like wait a second
5 X plus 1 is this guy right if you drew
in your tangents at every point pick a
point any point you like your tangent
will always have this same gradient
makes sense ok now this process it does
look very long we're going to be
replacing this process eventually
because so long but you need to know the
thing you're replacing with is doing
this in the background okay